when David Hy Pierce confirmed that he
wouldn't be reprising his role on the
rebooted Frasier fans were left
wondering what will happen Den NES will
he stay in Seattle or was he
unceremoniously killed off a recent
episode of the reboot finally gave us an
answer fans of highbrow humor rejoiced
when it was announced that Frasier was
coming back to Paramount plus however it
wasn't all good news as it also came to
light that David Hy Pierce would not
reprise the part of Fraser's brother
Niles citing his desire not to repeat
the same old roles however Niles is
still an integral component of this
universe so it only makes sense for the
reboot to address what happened to him
and whether he's even alive Frasier
viewers can rest easy Niles is still
alive so the chance of at least a cameo
materializing in the new show is still
on the table however fans would be
forgiven for wondering if Niles bit the
dust at some point because the reboot
has kept mom on what exactly went down
between him and Frasier the new season
contains a moment when Olivia mentions a
sibling rivalry to which Frasier
responds I am familiar with the
dynamic Frasier's response could hint at
the fact that the two simply aren't on
speaking terms which would explain why
Niles isn't around and why Frasier
doesn't talk about him much but seeing
how Frasier spends time with Nile son
David and David hasn't mentioned
anything about his father passing away
it's safe to say Niles is out there
somewhere given his status as a beloved
sitcom character it also makes sense
that Niles wouldn't be killed off in the
new Frasier series while David Hy Pier
may not want to make a habit of
returning to old roles he may be up for
a small appearance down the line after
all the original Frasier lasted for 11
Seasons so hopefully the Revival will
stick around for a while however in the
universe of the show it's kind of sad to
think that Frasier and Niles are no
longer close if Niles had died on
Frasier the characters could have moved
on but as it stands there's a huge hole
missing on the rebooted series and now
that Frasier is spending time with
Nile's son it's even weirder if he never
comes around the the two could remain
estranged within the series if Pierce is
adamantly against returning which would
be a sad end for the brothers and it
sort of shows how frer can never make
any familial relationships last the
Revival sees him move to Boston mostly
so that he can reconnect with his own
son Freddy Fraser never had a chance to
get close to him before and it may have
come at the expense of his relationship
with his brother taking a turn for the
worse of course it would be incredibly
cathartic for fans to see Niles again
the show could address why things may
have turned Frosty between the brothers
and even see them reconcile Niles
doesn't have to move to Boston with
everyone but just one episode of Frasier
and Niles joking around would be
delightful however if you miss seeing
Pierce on screen he has a new series to
watch he stars as Paul child in the
series Julia streaming on Max the 2022
drama covers the fruitful life of
American celebrity chef Julia Child
season 2 premiered in November 2023 but
due to the ongoing SE after strike you
likely haven't heard much about the
series so now is a better time than ever
to see how Pierce portrays Julia's
husband and creative partner as we wait
to see what future Niles has on the
small
[Music]
screen